Noora is with us from Washington Nora
quite a shift in relations between these
two men who were once very close yeah an
extraordinary really to hear from the
president's former fixer essentially
point the finger directly at the
President of the United States face
nation moderator and your senior foreign
affairs correspondent Margot Brennan
joins us this morning in Margaret we
were talking about this not only do you
hear Michael Cohen saying that the
president knew about it
he directed it and that he has given
evidence to the special counsel that
proves the president directed him to do
it what are the implications for the
president knowingly and willfully these
are the two words that we need to focus
on this is something that the president
says he did not sign off on didn't know
about just his legal counsel sort of
freelancing the reporting that is
significant from The Wall Street Journal
in the past few days that puts David
pecker the publisher of the National
Enquirer in the room with President
Trump when all this was being discussed
that's why it matters
that's knowingly that's willfully
Michael Cohen's saying here that the
President and candidate knew that what
he was doing was wrong the defenders as
ominous sounds like they were colluding
to influence the election that is right
and that is what President Trump says
that word has no no no grounding here
what he is also trying to say and his
defenders are that this is something
that the special counsel has kind of
gone off the rails this is beyond his
purview and that if this is in fact any
kind of crime it's not a serious enough
one to rise to the level if you also
look at some of the defenders of the
president they are now pointing figures
back at the FBI saying that some of this
was entrapment that the National
Security Advisor Michael Flynn was
essentially tricked into lying so you
were already seeing the strategies that
are going to be playing out in the new
Congress and we have a Democratic
majority here which is put all of this
in partisan terms at the same time the
Washington Post is reporting today that
robert muller quotes robert gray who is
a former special counsel that this
investigation may be coming to a close
it could happen in the first three
months of 2019
this comes as the White House doesn't
have a chief of staff who is president
Trump looking at well the president said
yesterday he has five candidates that
sound from the 10 he said just a few
days ago we were just talking before the
show it's interesting how wide open this
is that
one day you have Jared Kushner the
president's son-in-law rumored as being
under consideration something CBS has
confirmed the next day you have the man
who indicted his father Chris Christie
the former governor of New Jersey being
rumored is under consideration murder
actually he what's with the president
he's insulted on the issue certainly but
right now what we are seeing is such an
abiding what's interesting to have Jared
Kushner here is I think this emphasizes
well he may not ultimately get the job
this is the pinnacle of his influence in
Washington he's been on a streak
he has forced this criminal justice
reform bill something traditionally
supported by more liberal liberal
members or libertarian members on the
Republican leadership that was very
reluctant to even consider putting this
bill to a vote he won that argument
isn't law yet but at least he won that
that shows some influence and sway in
dealing with Capitol Hill a feather in
his cap and he just was honored by the
Mexican government for helping to save
this free trade deal so for those who
say he's a newbie it doesn't know
Washington he now seems to be asserting
himself in ways that are material it's
not just whispering in the president's
ear
all right market Brennan thank you so
much and we'll see Sun you Sunday
morning again and Face the Nation right
now it's in it back to New York all
right we'll look forward to face the
nation it's interesting what they were
saying about the speculation about chief
of staff I did an interview with Eric
Trump that first week right before the
inauguration I said what's gonna be the
hardest thing you think for your dad and
he said letting new people in our family
is very close and it's very difficult to
let new people in so Jared Kushner gets
that job that would be that would be
evidence of how they really like to keep
everything very close to the family so
you have a lot on his plate three big
things reelection in 2020 dealing with
the Democrats on trying to get anything
actually done in Washington and then of
course the mounting legal challenges to
the president both from the special
counsel the Southern District of New
York and the Democrats investigating the
chief of staff will be spinning plates
all day long and going back to your
point Gail throughout the campaign he
was his closest advisor no doubt exactly
and some big parlor game in Washington
we'll see